o Google então pulsos urbanos né porque
pontos urbanos eu pensei nisso logo
quando vocês me convidaram EA gente
começou a pensar nesse nome do evento
pulsos enredo a cidade custa necessidade
nenhuma estática cidade a dinâmica e
tudo que eu estudei tudo que eu faço na
minha vida enquanto arquiteto encontra
urbanista eu sempre levando isso em
consideração né quando a gente pensa
nessa palavra no urbano a gente logo
aparece uma série de palavra-chave que
vem em seguida pode ir
bom então quando a gente fala de urbano
quando a gente fala de cidade a gente
pensa a imediatamente em cidadão por
quem são as pessoas que participam dessa
cidade a gente pensa nos espaços
públicos e nas questões de gestão e de
planejamento e de participação eu não
sei se vocês lembram mas a primeira vez
que se criou o conceito de cidade o nome
a palavra cidade ver justamente disse de
participar Mas por outro lado quem
quiser participou de uma sessão pública
de fundamentos quem que costuma aí nas
sessões da câmara né quem que participam
de conselhos quem que participou da
revisão do último plano diretor na Então
imagina que vocês estão aqui presentes e
não serão muitos e isso porque a gente
tá no ambiente acadêmico né gente o
evento organizado dentro da UFG e então
o que que essa cidade que a gente tem
hoje será que a sua cidade ainda é uma
cidade o que que é urbano então quando a
gente fala e cidade em geral a gente tem
esse tipo de referência na nossa cabeça
C
e o seu outros tipos de espaços públicos
essa fotografia que se refere então a um
determinado tipo de cidade
e pode voltar
é essa cidade que a gente tem geralmente
quando a gente fala de espaços urbanos
da cidade vem na nossa cabeça uma série
de edifícios uma Via Rápida até aquela
fotografia com as manchas das luzes dos
veículos o ritmo que nunca pára né mas
essa fotografia é uma fotografia que
desmonta grossas e se a gente tá falando
então de espaços urbanos ele espaços
públicos essa fotografia se refere a um
espaço que é público que não é um espaço
privado eu não sei se vocês sabem da
onde é essa fotografia mas perto da
rodoviária no bairro da ronda olhando
para o bairro Estrela a gente tem um dos
muitos fundos de Vale aqui na cidade de
Ponta Grossa o parque boca da Honda que
será que já foi passear no parque boca
da ronda porque com esse nome
supostamente apareceu um parque né que a
gente desistir tudo mais e o parque boca
da ronda tem causas de pessoas que ali
vivem e não são casos de granadas quando
vem na nossa cabeça ocupação irregular a
gente pensar Nossa mas essas pessoas né
são violão elas ocuparam
a série elas em barracos elas vivem mal
não necessariamente né Mas por que então
que a gente tem uma casa em bom estado
de conservação com uma pessoa que não se
incomodou em aparecer na fotografia como
vocês podem ver dentro de um parque Essa
é a cidade que a gente tá que a gente
tem então essa cidade que a gente tem
que entender para qual cidade de qual
cidade que a gente faz parte e Como que
essa cidade se reflete na Disney ó
tô pensando Principalmente agora né no
nas questões acadêmicas e não estudante
ou um profissional que trabalha numa
universidade pública Como é o meu caso
Acho que o mais importante que a gente
tem a pensar é o tipo de espaço público
que eu frequento é um tipo de espaço
público que existe na minha cidade
quanto que vocês passaram por um espaço
parecido com aquele da outra imagem ao
vir aqui pro Campos provavelmente
ninguém porque na configuração da nossa
cidade os espaços públicos pelos quais a
gente passa são as avenidas são as ruas
principais que estão sempre nas partes
altas da cidade eu não vejo fundo de
vale eu não vejo aqui vindo pela Carlos
Cavalcanti recém-asfaltada eu penso
poderia atender a pensar não existe
pobreza em Ponta Grossa quantas letras é
um vi a tia fala né E existe próxima vez
que vocês tiverem na Carlos Cavalcanti
dobrinha direito e The Sims 3 ou 4
palavras e vocês vão ver que as pessoas
em situação de moradia irregular pessoas
que não tem esse a variável esgoto em
casa há 23
Oi gente agora né então quando a gente
pensa em espaços urbanos e aí vem na
nossa cabeça um espaço privado como esse
né que é um playground dentro de um
condomínio fechado perfeitamente é
resolvido utilizando a própria mata
ciliar do Rio como o sombreamento para
seu playground perfeito quando assim que
ensina arquitetura quando a gente ensina
engenharia muitas vezes é esse tipo de
produto que a gente está ensinando
porque a gente imagina que é esse tipo
de produto que vai ser projetado para os
nossos acadêmicos Mas será que isso
reflete a realidade todo mundo Será que
a maior parte das pessoas têm isso como
o dia a dia é esse espaço público dos do
qual participam né então em Ponta Grossa
a gente acaba tendo é um bom exemplo
nesse sentido parte dos rios perto das
ferrovias onde eram as antigas ferrovias
que viraram vias rápidas a gente tem ali
um espaço urbano e qualidade seja ele
público ou privado em outras ferrovias
em outros
e tem espaços urbanos muito mais
degradados mas como que acontece por quê
que isso acontece Será que sempre foi
assim será que ele acontece
espontaneamente né Qual que é a questão
então eu separei mais algumas imagens a
respeito aqui da cidade e eu gostaria de
cada um de vocês pensasse nisso quando
foi a última vez que vocês passaram por
áreas com essa cara aqui na cidade de
Ponta Grossa será que está comum Isso
faz parte do dia a dia porque não foi
necessário muito longe e não foi só em
um bairro da cidade que eu encontrei
esse tipo de situação né alguns ícones
que são muito presente na nossa vida com
o pessoas religiosas que somos né que
escolhemos aqui participar de um evento
para temos uma formação né como que a
gente vivência essa situação a gente
vive essa situação então
tô pensando em cidade a gente tem que
entender quais são os componentes que
fazem de uma cidade uma cidade uma
cidade instalar um núcleo populacional
Então tá localizada em algum lugar no
espaço em que uma sociedade se relaciona
existem fenômenos e relações sociais
culturais econômicos claramente isso
precisa de tempo para acontecer eu
comecei a minha fala dizendo que a
cidade é dinâmica né então como a gente
fala da produção social do espaço urbano
eu acho que esse é o único conceito
acadêmico que eu queria trazer para
assumir a sala para gente parar e mais
ou menos como aconteceu comigo quando eu
comecei a estudar cidade é uma chavinha
quebrou na minha cabeça quando eu
entendi que a cidade não é ela está e
que a cidade não é por acaso ela é
produto ela não é simplesmente porque
assim porque ficou assim ela é um
produto justamente dessas relações
nesses pastos por um período de tempo
então quando a gente fala produção
social do espaço urbano penas na cabeça
de vocês como a equação
e multiplique fatores e chego nesse
produto Essa é a cidade e se eu tenho
então um produto eu preciso ser agentes
que vão ser responsáveis por esse
produto que está sendo entregue num
contexto em que eu tenho desigualdade
essa desigualdade vai fazer com que as
pessoas se seguem nesse espaço urbano
posso ter situações de conflito de
resistências vou ter uma atuação super
importante do mercado por do do Estado
né do poder público e você também uma
ação importante do Poder privado quando
eu tiver esses atores que são muitas
vezes tem um alcance maior do que as
pessoas físicas né Eu vou ter esse
produto chamado cidade Só que não é só o
estado que pode ser produtor de espaço e
não são só as grandes incorporações
imobiliárias todos somos agentes para
modificação de espaço o espaço público
ele reflete essencialmente o público não
é privado a gente vai ter uma série de
outras questões mas os espaços públicos
eles vão refletir quem nós somos não é
de t
e não é porque o espaço público
degradado que eu só vou ter pessoas com
problemas sociais não é porque as
pessoas não são bem que o espaço vai
ficar ruim mas existe uma componente uma
relação muito forte e que a cidade
influencia em como o espaço vai
acontecer e aí como a sociedade vai se
desenvolver EA sociedade por sua vez
influencia no espaço
bom então o que que a gente quer
conversar hoje de todos esses problemas
que a gente falou né quando eu tenho uma
situação de degradação quando eu tenho
um problema fica muito fácil apontar
culpados né em que produz a cidade
afinal
em todas as fazendo a cabeça de vocês
provavelmente poder público poder
público é responsável por muita coisa
mas ir para quem que se produz a cidade
quem que é esse poder público esse poder
público não foi escolhido pela porque
ela gente foi escolhido por nós então
por que que as decisões do poder público
nem sempre correspondem Às nossas
expectativas né
a outra pergunta super importante da
gente fazer quando o espaço ele é
público Isso significa que ele é de
todos ou que ele não é de ninguém
quantas vezes vocês se sentiram a
vontade para vir até o e PG por exemplo
para fazer uma caminhada né quem costuma
usar esse espaço da UFCG Será que são só
os acadêmicos só os técnicos só os
docentes ou são todos a universidade ela
é como um micro clima né com uma pequena
cidade então será que não será a
universidade exatamente o melhor
laboratório para a gente entender o que
que pode ser diferente na nossa cidade
e se acha que pensar no poder público
porque que ela é tão apontado como um
agente importante na produção do espaço
porque ele tem alcance muito amplo não é
mesmo que a gente não queira aquilo que
a público a tem atinja todo mundo eu não
ia dar exatamente exemplo mas vamos
falar da distribuição de energia então
já que a gente teve uma surpresa hoje a
distribuição de energia a coleta de
esgoto todos os serviços públicos
atingem a todo mundo então por que que
Eu quando trabalhava como diretor de
projetos no Islã Pure fazer um projeto
de transporte público se eu não uso o
transporte público em Ponta Grossa Será
que isso Tá certo tá certo né porque não
tem uma formação na área né eu já tinha
um formação na área né porque isso
aconteceu mas será que não falta alguma
coisa será que o meu conhecimento
técnico conhecimento técnico que eu sou
capaz de passar pelos meus acadêmicos é
o suficiente para que eles estão numa
posição de valor nessa ser valorizados
como profissionais consigam realmente
impactar de maneira positiva na vida
e quando aparelho sobre participação
quando eu participo de uma audiência
pública quando eu tô lá participando de
um conselho e eu não confio nem verbo de
maneira errada eu sou mais levado a
sério quando as pessoas falam sobre o
meu currículo Entendeu Começar a falar
eu sou mais levado a sério então vê se
você tivesse entrado aquele falasse quem
que é essa aí eu não fosse para levar a
sério né então a gente tem que entender
que muitas vezes nós com nossa formação
né com o nível Educacional que a gente
consegue ter e por isso eu me dirigi
muito aos acadêmicos nós vamos ter
situações de poder nós vamos ter
situação de alcance para realmente mudar
a vida das pessoas então Que mudanças
que nós queremos promover uma mudança
justa ou uma mudança até indígena que a
gente acha que todo mundo passa pelos
mesmos problemas que nós mas na verdade
os problemas são diferentes são muitas
vezes mais graves né não poder público a
gente também muitas vezes tem que ficar
alimentações as famosas quebra ver com
utilidades descompassos de um governo
que o outro né
eu vou terminar porque foi o outro que
começou então esse tipo de coisa a gente
veio acontecendo né e muitas vezes
acontece no poder público que é alguém
que tem muito controle sobre as nossas
vidas e principalmente os últimos dois
itens que eu coloquei ele uma noção de
juízo de valor do que que é mais
importante e uma noção muito equivocada
da realidade invisibilização dessa
realidade às vezes não poder público
isso acontece eu falo por experiência
própria a gente não sabe que está
realmente acontecendo com a sociedade e
a gente perpetua noções equivocadas na
Minha tese doutorado eu fiz um
levantamento de dados em que pelos dados
do IBGE é não existe pobreza extrema em
Ponta Grossa simplesmente porque no
banco e coleta de dados as poucas casas
que geralmente as nossas favelas são
muito pequenas são menos que 20 casos
elas estão ali pertinho de casa de
altíssimo padrão o buraco da Honda ali
uma boca na rola é um desses exemplos eu
te
o ou seis ocupações irregulares e a 600
metros eu tenho a causa de um
ex-prefeito da cidade então é claro que
fazendo a média eu só tenho classe média
em Ponta Grossa não tem problema em
Ponta Grossa a universidade ele vai
intensidade não é a prefeitura que ele
vai ver se dado então eu começo a
enxergar um papel que é nossos de
mostrar esses outros caminhos de mostrar
essas outras realizadas muitas vezes a
percepção do próprio gestor por mais que
ele esteja bem intencionado não é igual
a percepção de um pesquisador Então qual
que é a solução e eu só consigo aponto
algo né Universidade nessas falas de
hoje a gente vai ter uma diversidade de
termos de temas de pessoas com
conhecimento técnico que é impossível de
passar em 18 minutos né acredito que
todos aqui vão terminar ensaiar para
conseguir chegar nesse limite de tempo
que a gente tem vontade dele abrir uma
porta outra porta e fundo no
conhecimento mas a gente tem que mostrar
aqui a nossa
e a gente tem um universo de temas a
serem tratados cada pessoa é um universo
não tem isso Então imagina você ser um
universo e você ter oportunidade eu
encontro professora foi uma oportunidade
de viver com acadêmicos de
personalidades variadas que vende
realidades variadas E tomara que cada
vez eu tenha mais acadêmicos com uma
realidade diferente da minha né então eu
consigo enxergar nos acadêmicos
realidades que eu não Vivi e eles como
multiplicadores vão também viver com
outras pessoas que têm outras percepções
juntando esse conhecimento técnico que é
muito variado para cada pessoa com o
nosso suporte com o nosso espaço não tem
como dar errado E é isso que aniversário
tem que significar é isso que a gente
tem o papel de mostrar e para
planejamento Urbano para ter uma gestão
continuada de fato a gente precisa estar
presente universidade tem que marcar
território esse fazer útil mostrar o
quanto a gente é útil porque potencial a
gente tem a gente tem potencial
e a princípio nós devemos ser imparciais
e quando eu falo em parciais eu quero
dizer conhecimento técnico né sem
favorecimentos a gente identifica
imparcialidade sempre mais temos que ser
acima de tudo ter conhecimento técnico
mas usar esse conhecimento técnico para
entender que existem pontos de vistas
diferentes que existem pessoas
diferentes que existem formas do
conhecimento diferença que não existe
juízo de valor entre elas certo a
sociedade ficava cidade a cidade faz a
cidade mas a universidade tem que ser
catalisador de suas relações eu gosto de
falar que a universidade tem que ser
óleo na engrenagem a gente tem o poder
público a gente tem poder privado o
mercado imobiliário quando você fala
planejamento a gente tem as ocupações
irregulares as pessoas em situação de
pobreza e a gente tem a Universidade a
universidade não é mais um não estão
todos no mesmo nível estão todos assim ó
agrupados e aniversário está ali no meio
fazendo a ponte entre cada um desses aí
bom então é nisso que eu acredito é isso
que eu pesquiso e eu agradeço muito pela
oportunidade de falar para vocês o